coronado high school students say they
are speaking up after several alleged
sexual assault incidents there's been an
ongoing protest outside the campus
throughout the entire day joe mueller
has been there talking to some of those
students he joins us live now with their
claims joe
out of the campus here today protesting
they say they're they're taking action
against some alleged sexual assault
incidents that happen both on and off
campus
[Applause]
hundreds gathered to send a message i
spoke to a few students who say several
female students were sexually assaulted
off campus and some say incidents
happened on campus they claimed they
accused our other students attending
school here kylie norcross says victims
came forward but nothing has happened
these women were sexually assaulted by
the student
and they came forward and they were not
they were not given justice the police
told them boys will be boys the students
say something needs to be done which is
why they left school and came out to
protest the district referred us to
henderson police regarding these
allegations
now back out here live the henderson
police department just got back to us a
short time ago and they said that this
is an open investigation into those
allegations reporting live in henderson
joe mohler live local now